kourtney kardashian and travis barker
enjoy a date night with megan fox and
machine gun kelly
the reality star and the actress were at
ufc 260 in las vegas on saturday night
with their respective boyfriends as they
watched francis and ganu
defeat stipe miovich fox and kelly made
playful faces as cameras spotted them in
the vip section at the ufc apex
next to the 41 year old pooch founder
and the blink 182 drummer
who color coordinated in edgy black
ensembles
now a source tells e.t that the couples
have had double date nights
many times and are all good friends
quote they have a great time when they
hang out as couples and it's very
natural
easy and fun the source adds that they
have a lot of shared
interests like music self-care practices
and more quote courtney and travis are
super into each other and
megan and machine gun kelly are so in
love so it's nice for both couples to
spend time with like-minded people
i love it travis and kelly have known
each other for years and have
collaborated on several projects
most recently they worked together on
kelly's album tickets to my downfall
the 30 year old and fox started dating
after meeting
last year on the set of their upcoming
movie midnight in the switchgrass
meanwhile barker and kardashian have
been dating for a few months after
turning their longtime friendship into
something more
a source told et earlier this month
courtney and travis are in total lust
over each other
and she doesn't regret going public with
their relationship at all
the relationship was a long time coming
because the attraction has always been
there
on both sides they love the fact that
they have a true friendship
and bonded that way before taking
anything further and making things
romantic i'm just like
living life and whatever happens happens
and get this fans are speculating that
the 45 year old musician's new tattoo
is in honor of his leading lady
barker recently posted that video
getting inked with the words
you're so cool shortly after he posted
the clip
kardashian slid into the comments
writing just that
you're so cool i'll remember that
forever
fans went wild theorizing that the tat
might have been written
in her handwriting barker later
explained that the line comes from
patricia arquette's character in the
1993 film
true romance after she writes it on a
napkin
me and my wife were minimum wage kids
you know 200 thousand dollars it means a
world-ass
the rocker has previously said in
interviews that true romance is his
favorite movie
so much so that he named his
fifteen-year-old daughter alabama
after arquette's character oh and
earlier this
year kardashian shared screenshots from
true romance on social media
and barker he commented with what else
you're so cool
you